Traduttore: Alessio Politi
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Utopia o realtà?
Obiettivo raggiungibile,
concreto, fattibile;
o pura follia
in un mondo sempre più determinato
da logiche consumistiche
dello spreco dei materiali,
dell'usa e getta?
Beh secondo me "Rifiuti Zero" è possibile.
Non solo è possibile,
ma anzi è necessario, è fondamentale,
per costruire un futuro sostenibile.
Anzi, per costruire un futuro possibile.
Perché non esiste un futuro possibile,
senza sostenibilità.
Iniziamo questo breve viaggio
da due grafici e da due immagini.
Il primo grafico ci dice
un dato molto semplice
e preoccupante allo stesso tempo:
il consumo di materie all'anno
sul pianeta Terra.
Negli ultimi 100 anni,
e per i prossimi 30.
Se oggi siamo intorno
a 85 giga-tonnellate l'anno,
entro i prossimi 30 anni, in questo trend,
arriveremo a 170 giga-tonnellate l'anno.
Peccato che, gli scienziati ci dicono,
non le avremo sul nostro pianeta.
E non ne abbiamo un altro di scorta.
Quindi dobbiamo capire
come poter conciliare
i limiti fisici del nostro pianeta
con un diverso modello di sviluppo.
L'altro grafico ci dice
un'altra cosa altrettanto importante:
è l'andamento delle
emissioni climalteranti,
la CO2 in atmosfera negli ultimi anni.
Un andamento crescente
che ha determinato cambiamenti climatici,
gli scienziati ci dicono,
per circa un grado sul nostro pianeta.
Quindi è un po' come se avessimo
la febbre intorno a 37.
L'accordo di Parigi stabilisce
che dobbiamo stare
entro i due gradi, al massimo,
di cambiamenti climatici.
Altrimenti, per l'umanità,
sarà molto, molto pericoloso e difficile
continuare a vivere su questo pianeta.
Meglio tenerci entro il grado e mezzo,
quindi questo è l'andamento
che dobbiamo dare
alle nostre emissioni
climalteranti in atmosfera
se vogliamo stare entro i due gradi,
o meglio, perché è meno rischioso,
entro il grado e mezzo.
Quindi se non vogliamo arrivare a scenari
che sarebbero davvero preoccupanti.
E questo viaggio continuiamolo
in una bellissima città italiana.
Chi di voi è mai stato a Venezia?
Città meravigliosa.
Ecco, peccato, perché Venezia,
come tutte le città di mare,
saranno le prime che pagheranno
le conseguenze più dure e devastanti
dei cambiamenti climatici,
con l'innalzamento dei mari
che renderà sempre più difficile
vivere in queste città.
Ma andiamo dall'altra parte del mondo.
L'11 marzo 2017,
una frana nella discarica di Addis Abeba
genera 65 morti,
per lo più donne e bambini,
che lì intorno vivevano
per raccogliere materiali,
anche i nostri rifiuti,
e continuare a dare vita a quel materiale
estraendoci ancora un po'
di quel valore che ancora hanno.
Ecco, questa immagine non può
che suscitarci due riflessioni.
Una è una scossa di responsabilità,
che ognuno di noi ha
per ogni scelta che fa.
E l'altra è l'alternativa.
Le alternative che dobbiamo far crescere.
Più aumentiamo la responsabilità
di ognuno di noi
più facciamo crescere alternative.
Più le alternative crescono,
e prendono forza,
più possiamo far crescere
la responsabilità collettiva.
E le alternative esistono.
È proprio l'Europa che ci sta spingendo,
sta spingendo tutti i paesi europei
ad andare verso modelli
di economia circolare.
Perché la nostra economia, perlopiù,
è tradizionalmente lineare:
Estrai; Produci; Consuma; Scarta.
E invece quello scarto
deve ritornare come materia prima
nella sostituzione dell'estrazione
continua di materie prime,
altrimenti non avremo, senz'altro,
né futuro né sostenibilità.
Ma la strategia Rifiuti Zero
punta a obiettivi ancora più ambiziosi,
quali quelli, appunto,
di ridurre la produzione
dei rifiuti sul nostro pianeta.
E, se fino a qualche anno fa, appunto,
parlare di Rifiuti Zero
sembrava un'utopia,
qualche mese fa ho avuto l'onore
di essere il primo relatore internazionale
del primo congresso mondiale
di tutte le città Rifiuti Zero.
Ci siamo trovati a Brasilia,
la capitale del Brasile;
e c'erano città di tutto il mondo,
dall'Australia al Giappone,
all'Asia, all'Africa, agli Stati Uniti.
E lì abbiamo avuto la consapevolezza
che siamo un movimento
che sta crescendo nel mondo
e che sempre più costruisce
risultati e vantaggi.
Una delle più grandi città del mondo
che ha fatto questa scelta
è San Francisco.
Oltre un milione di abitanti,
che ha avviato politiche di riciclo
per oltre l'80% dei propri scarti
e con questo ha evitato la costruzione
di una nuova discarica.
Ha creato decine, centinaia
di migliaia di posti di lavoro
attraverso politiche
di raccolta differenziata, riciclo,
riuso dei materiali fondamentali.
E nel 2007, vedendo proprio
l'esempio di San Francisco,
in Italia -
abbiamo voluto portare anche in Italia,
perché nessuna comunità aveva fatto ancora
questa scelta, questo percorso.
E siamo partiti da Capannori,
un comune di circa 50.000 abitanti,
in provincia di Lucca,
a voler costruire questa nuova sfida.
E tanti, tantissimi
ci dicevano che era un'utopia,
che era impossibile
arrivare a rifiuti zero.
Ma abbiamo agito su queste due leve:
la responsabilità e le alternative,
in un percorso di coinvolgimento
della cittadinanza
e in costruzione di alternative
che alimentassero la responsabilità.
Quindi siamo partiti
dal primo passo fondamentale,
cioè quello di eliminare
i sistemi di raccolta
che alimentano irresponsabilità,
come i sistemi di raccolta a cassonetto.
Sembrava di infrangere una religione,
a togliere i cassonetti per strada,
10 - 12 anni fa;
oggi, per fortuna,
è una politica che fanno sempre più città
in Italia e nel mondo,
per organizzare, invece,
sistemi di raccolta domiciliari
che alimentano la responsabilità
perché così ognuno è obbligato
a prendere in mano i propri scarti,
domandarsi e aumentare
le proprie responsabilità.
È proprio attraverso queste politiche
che abbiamo costruito
questo risultato incredibile,
che sembrava impossibile.
Vedete in questo semplicissimo grafico,
il rosso è tutto quello
che prima,una decina di anni fa,
andava a smaltimento.
E si sta assottigliando sempre più,
tendenzialmente verso zero,
grazie a due fattori fondamentali:
l'aumento delle raccolte differenziate,
e la riduzione della
produzione dei rifiuti.
Dove l'elemento centrale
è stata la responsabilità dei cittadini
che abbiamo alimentato tramite, appunto,
questo meccanismo semplice e banale
che è la necessità di doversi chiedere
ogni scarto dove va.
E allora ci si inizia a chiedere
anche perché facciamo tanti scarti.
Iniziamo a vederli,
e quindi a capire il problema.
Ma, abbiamo detto, è importante
anche ridurre, i rifiuti.
E le prime cose che possiamo fare,
per chi ha la possibilità,
è agire sull'organico.
L'organico è circa
il 40% dei rifiuti urbani,
è quello che crea maggiori problemi
quando finisce in discarica,
perché crea percolato,
crea tantissimi problemi ambientali.
E quindi, per chi ha la possibilità
di farsi il compostaggio domestico,
e quindi di trattarli in casa,
nell'orto nel giardino,
è il primo passo da fare.
Così non facciamo viaggiare
in camion quel materiale,
e ridiamo alla terra
quegli elementi nutritivi importanti
che gli abbiamo tolto
per fare coltivazioni.
Quindi è la prima basilare cosa da fare
per costruire sostenibilità ambientale.
Ma chi abita in una città
non ha la possibilità di farselo,
quindi ci sono sempre
più impianti industriali
che permettono di trasformare
le nostre bucce di patata
non solo in compost di qualità
che viene utilizzato in agricoltura,
ma anche in sostituzione
di carburante, in biometano
come questo impianto
che è a Pinerolo in Piemonte
e dove appunto si produce biometano
che alimenta quei mezzi che fanno
la raccolta dei rifiuti in quella zona.
Quindi un modello perfetto
di economia circolare
che sempre più si sta replicando
in tante città italiane.
Ma, dopo l'organico, passiamo
ai materiali riciclabili, secchi:
la carta, la plastica, i metalli.
Su ognuna di queste filiere industriali
potremmo fare una relazione lunghissima,
e scoprire viaggi meravigliosi
attraverso le politiche del riciclo
che generano,
attraverso impianti molto più semplici
di quelli di smaltimento,
generano molta più occupazione.
Si calcola che sia circa
quattro / cinque volte di più
il rendimento economico e occupazionale
degli impianti di riciclo,
rispetto agli impianti di smaltimento.
Ma abbiamo detto che Rifiuti Zero
non punta solo a fare questo primo passo,
cioè avviare a riciclo tutti i materiali,
ma ha l'ambizione di voler ridurre,
anche, la produzione dei rifiuti.
E non è vero
che ridurre la produzione di rifiuti
sia sinonimo di privazione,
perché invece,
in tantissime progettualità,
per ridurre i rifiuti
si è unita la riduzione dei rifiuti
allo sviluppo economico.
Ad esempio, questo banalissimo
e semplicissimo progetto
che con un'azienda in Piemonte
ci ha visto creare due marchi
dell'eco ristorazione e dell'eco albergo
e li abbiamo riconosciuti
a quelle attività della ristorazione
e a quegli alberghi
che hanno adottato un protocollo d'intesa
accettando di attuare
almeno sette azioni, su dieci possibili,
per ridurre gli impatti ambientali
e la produzione di rifiuti
nelle loro attività commerciali.
Questo ha dato loro pubblicità,
quindi li ha fatti conoscere,
e ne hanno beneficiato
in termini economici.
L'ambiente ne ha beneficiato,
perché appunto si sono
prodotti meno rifiuti
e anche l'economia locale
ne ha beneficiato,
perché si è avviato
lo smaltimento: meno rifiuti.
E quindi anche i cittadini
hanno avuto un beneficio,
quindi tutti ne hanno vinto.
Come questi sono decine,
centinaia di progettualità
che si possono attuare
nel campo della riduzione dei rifiuti
per unire tutti i tipi di vantaggi:
sociali, ambientali,
economici e occupazionali.
L'altro passo fondamentale,
sempre per ridurre i rifiuti,
è allungare il loro ciclo di vita,
ad esempio attraverso i centri del riuso.
Qualche anno fa ho visitato
questo spettacolare posto
che è il più grande
centro europeo del riuso.
L'ha costruito la città di Göteborg,
investendo quattro milioni di euro.
E in questo spazio lavorano 30 persone.
Ogni giorno 200 cittadini vanno,
e acquistano qualsiasi cosa:
una porta, una finestra,
un sanitario, un elettrodomestico.
E in questo modo,
dopo avere dato lavoro, ogni anno,
a più di 30 persone,
versano al Comune gli utili di impresa.
Mediamente sono
tra i 7-800.000 euro all'anno,
quindi un investimento
alquanto redditizio per il Comune.
Ecco, la stessa cosa
l'abbiamo realizzata a Capannori,
proprio all'interno
della strategia Rifiuti Zero,
con un centro che si chiama Daccapo.
Che quindi dà vita, ritorna a dar vita
a tutti i materiali che vengono conferiti,
e dà lavoro a sette persone.
E questo è, appunto, un modello
che si sta sempre più replicando
in tante tante città in giro per l'Italia.
Ma passiamo a un passo ulteriore
della strategia Rifiuti Zero,
quello della tariffazione puntuale.
Cosa significa?
Significa applicare quel concetto banale
a cui da sempre siamo abituati a pensare
quando consumiamo l'acqua
e quindi la paghiamo
in funzione di quanta ne consumiamo;
oppure la luce,
in funzione di quanta
ne consumiamo e paghiamo.
Perché non deve essere così
anche per i rifiuti?
Proprio per alimentare quel senso
di responsabilità contro lo spreco,
che la bolletta dell'acqua o della luce
ci incentiva, diciamo, a fare.
E quindi, a partire da questo concetto,
abbiamo fatto un'innovazione,
qualche anno fa, appunto, a Capannori
inserendo, per la prima volta in Italia,
un RFID, un microscopico microchip,
che applicato nel sacco,
o anche nel bilancino,
inserisce appunto i dati dell'utenza,
che quindi è registrata
per ogni conferimento
di materiale indifferenziato che fa.
E questo permette di capire
quante volte, in ogni anno,
il cittadino ha conferito i propri scarti.
Questo progetto è stato candidato
a un concorso che si chiama
Innovation In Politics
e, ringraziando anche
tutti i miei collaboratori,
abbiamo vinto quel concorso
come primo e unico esperimento, in Italia,
di questa progettualità.
Voglio farvi vedere il video
che loro hanno fatto proprio
per riassumere il nostro progetto.
Community.
Waste does not pay:
cities rewards and punishes
families' waste management habits.
Tariffa Puntuale
introduces rewards and penalties
for families and businesses
in order to minimize non recyclable waste.
As the first town in Italy
to adopt a zero waste strategy,
Capannori puts waste tariffs
on the same level
as those for energy and water,
linking the cost to the amount
of non recyclable waste produced.
This method encourages
all households and businesses
to maximize waste separation,
which, through recycling,
generates value from waste,
and extrends its life.
Ecco,
se con percorsi di raccolta differenziata
domiciliari, responsabilizzati,
arriviamo al 70 - 80%
di avvio al riciclo di materiali,
con la tariffazione puntuale
possiamo arrivare anche al 90 - 95%.
L'abbiamo fatto a Capannori
e ora lo sto facendo
in tante altre comunità
seguendole in questo percorso
di attuazione semplice, banale,
che dimostra una cosa semplicissima:
che non esistono distanze
che possano non permettere
di realizzare questi percorsi
perché ci sono percorsi simili
al Sud, al Centro e al Nord Italia,
in piccole, grandi e medie città.
Quindi basta la volontà
di voler raggiungere questi obiettivi.
Ma non è detto che quel 10%,
quel 5%, 15% che sia,
che va ancora a smaltimento,
debba continuare ad andare
a smaltimento all'infinito,
perché così come il mercato
delle materie prime
è in continua crescita di costo,
perché sono sempre più scarse
le materie prime,
lo stesso le industrie,
anche le grandi multinazionali
stanno investendo sempre di più
per andare a prelevare
il valore dei nostri scarti.
Non a caso vengono definite
"le miniere urbane", i nostri scarti.
E non a caso, proprio in Italia,
una grande multinazionale ha realizzato,
in provincia di Treviso, questo impianto.
Questo impianto che,
per la prima volta al mondo,
ricicla i pannolini.
I pannolini dei nostri bambini
che, dopo una fase
di sterilizzazione iniziale,
vengono riciclati attraverso l'estrazione
di materie cellulosiche
e materie plastiche
che vanno nelle filiere della carta
e del recupero delle materie plastiche.
E lo stesso succede a questo materiale.
Questo materiale si chiama pulper,
ed è lo scarto del riciclo della carta.
Sono le copertine, magari,
dei quaderni dei nostri figli,
che finiscono per sbaglio
nella raccolta differenziata;
oppure sono quelle etichette trasparenti
nelle buste che riceviamo a casa,
che quindi sono una materia estranea
nella raccolta differenziata
e finiscono a smaltimento.
Ma, se fino a pochi mesi fa
finivano solo a smaltimento,
da qualche settimana,
grazie a un'innovazione importantissima
di un'azienda del territorio,
e un finanziamento importante
a livello europeo,
questo materiale va a riciclo.
E quindi, gran parte
di questo materiale viene intercettato
e si sta avviando una filiera industriale
per trasformarlo in pallet
che poi viene usato da altre aziende
per la logistica interna.
Allora, se abbiamo visto
che fino a qualche anno fa ci dicevano
che era utopia, era impossibile,
erano obiettivi irraggiungibili.
Oggi abbiamo visto che, invece,
sono sempre di più i vantaggi
che si costruiscono dalla fattibilità
di questi percorsi.
E ci stiamo togliendo
anche qualche soddisfazione,
perché quando riceviamo queste conferme,
queste riconoscenze istituzionali -
questo è il segretario europeo
per l'Ambiente, Vella,
che appunto un paio d'anni fa,
in un convegno in cui abbiamo illustrato
le migliori esperienze italiane
nella gestione dei rifiuti,
ha affermato che proprio questi sono
quei principi ispiratori
del pacchetto dell'economia circolare
su cui anche l'Europa sta lavorando
per spingere tutti i paesi europei
verso la sostenibilità, il riciclo
e la riduzione dei rifiuti.
Io vi voglio lasciare
con un'immagine stupenda,
che è la Sacra di San Michele in Piemonte.
Cosa ci dice questa immagine?
Che salendo c'è una salita
terrificante, faticosissima.
Ma ci dice proprio questo:
di arrivare lassù, che si vede
un meraviglioso paesaggio.
E tutte le volte che ci si va,
si capisce che ne è valsa la pena.
Ma si capisce anche un'altra cosa:
che da quel bellissimo paesaggio
si vedono mete e obiettivi ancora più alti
da dover raggiungere,
da poter raggiungere.
È bellissimo,
e la cosa bellissima
non è tanto raggiungerle
quanto il cammino
che possiamo fare per raggiungerle
e di quanto capiamo,
conosciamo e scopriamo
nel percorso che facciamo
per cercare di raggiungerlo.
Io ho dei figli.
E quando li guardo
voglio essere sicuro di aver fatto
tutto il possibile, e l'impossibile,
per non lasciare a loro un disastro
come invece, purtroppo,
spesso vediamo e scopriamo
che stiamo facendo al nostro pianeta.
Auguro a tutti voi un buon lavoro.
Grazie.
(Applausi)